morning david finish your crosstalk
quickly
there i've just had a message from terry
two he's having technical difficulties
getting in but he's gonna keep trying so
um i don't know how that affects
apologies and things
[Music]
um think sylvia's arrived
uh councillors orman councillors russell
i don't think you have your counselor us
on your devices on mute now council
romeo oh thank you for that
thank you very much
[Music]
um chair we're now live streaming so
thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to
our full council meeting on the 23rd of
november
firstly i would like to introduce my
chaplain mark
jones who will lead us in prayer mark
thank you john well i've been thinking
about this um
even though we're still in november i
honestly can't think of a single
christmas like the one that we're about
to try and celebrate
it's going to be a christmas way for one
thing there's such complete and total
agreement that
we all want the new year to be
completely new
and and different and better than this
year
there's an old u2 song that says nothing
changes on new year's day i hope and
pray this year this coming year that
these words will be wholly wrong
seems to be a real hunger for christmas
this year as many predicted months ago
the british people are putting up their
christmas decks early
just like our stoic wartime mentality of
80 years ago
we're determined to celebrate christmas
anyway and given half a chance we're
going to make something good happen
for us and our friends and family
what's more the prospect of three or
more working vaccines as
has lifted our heads to look up and
believe in the future again
evidence of the simple power of hope
hope drives us on it it encourages us to
persist in moving forwards
someone said without hope the human
spirit very quickly withers on the vine
it seems that hope is arriving again
this christmas time in paul's letter to
the church in rome we read this
concerning hope if we already have what
we hope for
there is no need to keep on hoping
instead we hope for something we have
not yet
seen and we wait patiently for it
as ever if you are not a person of faith
please use these brief moments to think
and reflect on these things
let's pray our father we first and
foremost want to thank you for
the imminent prospect of real effective
vaccines
that will inflict a devastating blow
on the coronavirus and we thank you for
these scientific breakthroughs and for
those who've worked around the clock
to deliver them in record time
help those now planning the gargantuan
logistical operation
that will enfold unfold around the world
over the coming months
and we ask that you grant us patience to
wait our turn
for these tiny pinpricks that will
change the game for us personally
and change the narrative for the whole
world
god we thank you for each other
different as we are and we ask that you
grant each person
serving here today the same spirit of
cooperation and pulling together
that is working now to extricate
humanity
from this pandemic help us all to do our
part in this
and grant us hope not just for a vaccine
that works
but for an altogether more sustainable
fairer
and harmonious future for everyone in
the team bridge area and beyond
through john's mature and impartial
chairing of this meeting please direct
and guide this council in all its
consultations
in all its deliberations in all its
decisions
we thank you for hearing our prayers
feeding us with your word
and encouraging us in our meeting
together in jesus name
amen amen thank you very much indeed
mark
thank you democratic services would you
call it a role call for attendance
please
counselor austin president
councillor bradford present
councillor billavent councillor clarence
president
cancer colclough present
councillor connect and present
councillor david cox
president councillor hugh cox um
councillor dawes i'm here cancer
dewhurst
present councillor eden yeah
that's the goodman bradbury present
councillor gribble present councillor
haynes
present councillor hocking
councillor gordon hook answer jackie
hook
councillor jeffrey councillor jenks
councillor keeling present
cancer care as well present
council mcgregor president
councillor morgan president
councillor malone president
councillor natalie president councillor
president councillor
present councillor parker khan
president counselor patch present
cancer pit present
counselor linda pedreck present
councillor phipps
councillor persa president councillor
rolison
president councillor russell president
councillor swain here cancer
councillor parker cancer john petherick
rob rob it's the
full council now
uh members uh meeting protocol just a
few notes if i may please
uh please ensure your microphone is on
mute when you're not speaking
because we just heard some background
noise and that's what happens
please ensure your camera is kept on
during the actual meeting
should a comfort bakery required it will
take place before the part two item is
considered
or at a one and a half hour point should
the that will fit in with the agenda
when we take our comfort break please
ensure that both your microphone
and camera is switched off should
members wish to comment on
any of the agenda items please raise
your blue hand
i have 56 people on the screen at the
moment it's very difficult to
to see if i get to see your hands so
hands only
should you wish to speak a few
introductions we have some guests with
us today
we have councillor bryony rudkin who's
the deputy leader of ipswich council
bridget downton who's the head of
business insight and corporate
communications
dorset council richard crawley planning
advisory service
and paul clark from the aga later
when we get to agenda item seven they
will give a presentation on their
findings
of on for of the um langford bridge
inquiry
additionally we have um uh two members
of staff
from our external auditors grant
thornton
james jane massey and andrew davis and
they will
speak to us on agenda eight and eight a
gentleman item eight
um are there any apologies for absence
please
i have apologies from councillors evans
foden hayes jeffries and cook
okay thank you for that
chairman they also apologize from cancer
jinx
okay yep thank you for that leader thank
you
chairman i have a counsellor fix and
counselor team who are having technical
difficulties trying to get into the
meeting
okay okay thank you any more
okay thank you very much so item two on
the agenda
which is the minutes for the full
council meeting on the 30th of september
our members in agreement that they are
an accurate representation of what
actually took place
i'm not in agreement um
so we've had a proposal on council alone
you're not in agreement what what are
you not in agreement with
uh 0.49 uh councillors questions the
penultimate sentence
the council could have considered
declining the request on these grounds
due to the cost of compliance um
according to ici ico guidelines it could
not
have reasonably declined the request on
those grounds
um i don't think this point is true
the ico wrote to the council twice
telling them to fulfill this foi request
this just seems like a point trying to
codify a point of uh
of stamping down on transparency to me i
don't think it's necessary
so i would i would like the penultimate
sentence struck from the
minutes i understand what you're saying
counselor
i'm the leader would you like to respond
to that one please
um it's uh a minute of what was said at
the meeting uh i under i understand what
council malone is saying but believe the
minutes are meant to record
uh the general context of the meeting so
i need to take advice from the
monitoring officer or the
managing director if members feel that
they wish to amend the meaning
chair it's not a minute that records
a fact it's a minute that records an
opinion
uh chairman perhaps advice from the
monitoring officer
on on the minutes of the meeting council
malone has raised the query members will
need to decide whether
it was on that record or to strike it so
best that we take
advice thank you could the monitoring
officer respond please
um thank you chair um as the leader has
said it's a
it's a record of what was actually
discussed clearly there's lots of things
that may be said at a meeting that
people might not agree with
so um if it was said or its reflection
of what was said it should remain in the
minutes
but um there's nothing further that can
be added with regards to that
unfortunately
thank you okay so thank you for that so
any other members not content for the
minutes
yes uh i'm uh not content with the
minutes uh there's the same point
actually
um if uh if the meeting minutes need to
reflect what was said uh i think it
would be a good point of record
for it to be uh noted that the leader
told me
uh to man up uh i'd like that to be a
point of public record
but more seriously well maybe that is a
serious point
but more meaningfully uh i asked two
supplementary questions
at the meeting which have not been
recorded
or indeed answered and those
supplementaries
relate to standards there was a concern
from a neighboring council
a portfolio holder who wrote an email to
the
chair of standards richard keeling
stated i've never met the gentleman
or had contact with them but i agree
that this was a smear campaign which
gives local government a bad name
i will be writing to the lga to
uh express my concerns my question was
whether what the council would doing to
react to that
question uh and then my second
supplementary
was in relation to the ico questions
and the leaders my supplementary
question was the leader's reply seems to
indicate that sharing information
is a choice or is tight weight it's tied
to covid
the ico and tdc uh reminded
uh team bridge of their legal
obligations
uh and that the residents wanted to
understand
why there's a repeated pattern of
failure to satisfy fois sars
e i rs for us and other parties
that was asked at the meeting i would
like it recorded and i would like my
other supplementary recorded uh
i think on the point that the monitoring
officer noted there
uh they should be thank you councillor
doors i mean your first point um
minutes are not actually verbatim with
what was said i mean it's just a
just a general coverage of of the the
content of the of
any comments were made now if you've
asked supplementary questions
and uh they haven't been responded to
who were they directed to
they were both answered by the leader at
the meeting
uh initially and the supplementaries
would thus
uh made to the leader yeah so so the
leader has responded then
no i i put the i put the supplementaries
in
at the meeting of which there's a
there's a youtube video of
uh i have that they're not recorded in
the minutes
uh i put the supplementaries in in
writing so that there's a record so that
the
comsec had them uh and i had no response
that was put in on the 8th of october
i think you've made your point there so
leader of council would you like to
respond
chairman the minutes have been moved i
second them um
people are entitled to make an amendment
if they wish to we've heard advice from
the
monitoring officer chairman i'm content
for the minutes i would ask members for
their support
yes in that case then um i see that
we've got to a couple other balloon
hands as well
um counselor eden
thank you just a quick thought i can see
how when people look at minutes who
aren't
part of this bubble they might they
might come across
as being statements of sort of absolute
fact
so i'm just wondering whether we should
actually be clearer on the at the front
of our lives
i think therein lies the trouble because
when someone's doing
clearly people can argue about them and
that's that's why we have this
point in the agenda so i think what i'm
saying is that perhaps to clarify for
the public the fact that our minutes
don't record
cast iron fat they just record what
somebody said and perhaps it should say
who said various things
thanks thank you for your it sounds like
it's an authoritative declaration
thank you councillor eden uh councillor
patch
thank you thank you chairman um you're
just listening to the comments on the
minutes i do wonder if there's a case
that
um one of the officers goes back can
actually sort of
reference to the recording of the
meeting does
look to certainly amend um points of
facts
um such as non-inclusion of
supplementary questions
and then the minutes be brought back to
us at a future meeting
um i don't know whether that's it's an
appropriate to move that as an amendment
but certainly that would be my feeling
as the way forward
i have to say i'm not inclined to agree
with you council department it's been
proposed and seconded
could i propose an amendment that we
include my supplementary questions uh as
they were asked
i'll second that
i said that you've put your blue hand up
thank you just to point out that the
mid the actual meeting is recorded it is
available on youtube
people can see the actual detail and
therefore i think a summary of
as presented is fine understood so
just just find a word from the leader of
the council
um chairman unless i misheard the
last four council was the 30th of
september to which councillor dawes
asked his supplementary questions and
presented them orally then
um if i i don't think i miss her but i
think then
counselor door said he then submitted
his supplementaries on the 8th of
october
um well i couldn't possibly have
answered supplementaries on the 8th of
october
at a meeting which was on the 30th of
september chairman
so again i move i'm happy to second the
minutes that set out
thank you thank you so can we can we go
to the vote please
no democratic services don't we vote on
the amendment
democratic services guidance please the
monitoring officer would like to say
something
thank you so much if you just yeah
chair um you have a valid amendment
before you whether members agree with it
or not is another matter of course
you need to take the vote on the
amendment first okay
uh thank you for that so we'll vote on
the amendment and council doors could
you
define exactly what your amendment is
please my amendment is that i would like
the supplementaries that were asked at
the meeting
and were then forwarded on an email as a
matter of record on the 8th of october
as i suspected they may not have been uh
minuted
uh for the for the supplementaries that
were asked at the meeting to be included
as a record of the meeting thank you for
that and that's been seconded by
councillor agent patch so
so could we please vote on the amendment
then
councillor austin
councillor austin four
councillor bradford four councillor bill
evans
or councillor clarence
port councillor colclough
paul councillor connect
against councillor david cox
i'm against because paragraph 49
effectively does what the
amendment pros it proposes to do so i'm
against because it's unnecessary
councillor hugh cox against
doors four councillor dewhurst
against councillor eden or
cancer goodman bradbury against
against
jeffrey cancer keeling
against cancer care as well
or cancer mcgregor
against councillor morgan
against hanson malone
or councillor natalie against
councillor nettle against
councillor i couldn't attend the meeting
because of my tea issues so i shall have
to
abstain cancer park account
for camps of patch
or council of peat
council linda pedreck
four councillor rolison
against councillor russell
councillor swain uh against i have
reread the minutes
councillor taylor against
cancer thorne or
cancer wrigley against it's already
covered in paragraph 49
councillor parker against
council john pedreck against
chair we verified the votes it's uh 19
4 19 gates with one abstention
so um we'd like to go to the chairs
casting vote thank you well i've already
voted against once i
vote against it again in that case thank
you
thank you so do we know we now go back
to the
original proposal do we know is that
correct
yeah go back to the original proposal
for the minutes
okay it's been proposed and seconded
okay thank you for that
so they've been proposed and seconded so
members are in favor that the minutes
are adopted please
roll call please
council austin
four council bradford
against cancer bill event
cancer clarence cancer colclough
council of connect
cancer david cox thought counselor hugh
cox
[Music]
goodman bradbury or
gordon hook
cancer gordon hook
counselor jackie hook paul
counselor jeffrey
cancer keeling four
councillor kurzweil council mcgregor
or councillor morgan four
councillor malone against
councillor natalie four councillor
nettle
[Music]
councillor nuttel
councilor piet paul
councillor linda pedreck
council linda petherick four
council persa four councillor rollerson
four councillor russell
councillor swain four councillor taylor
four councillor thorne or
councillor wrigley four
councillor parker four councillor
petherek
john pederick four
that's carrick chair thank you very much
indeed for that thank you
so moving on now to item three which is
announcements from myself i just have
the one announcement i i've recently
attended
the the the recently introduced uh
covert 19 updates which have been
delivered by by the leader
i found them to be very very useful um
they focus on members on the enormous
levels of community assistance that
team bridge has has been engaged with
additionally it's helped us to
appreciate precisely
what is happening at the sharp end i
also took the opportunity to write a
thank you to the md
to be passed on to our staff because
they deserve the
recognition for their dedication was
navigating towards a new normal
uh they go to tremendous length now to
get that not only their jobs done but
also to cope like us
with covid19 and they're managing it
also within their own family in need so
thank you very much indeed to our staff
moving on now to item four are there any
declarations of interest
i take that as no no declarations of
interest
uh public questions i am not aware of
any is that correct
you've had no public questions chair
thank you for that thank you
um and cancel the questions we have a
number of counsellor questions
um the first one is from cancer
boulevard
that's been responded so
do you have a supplementary counselor
willow thank you very much
um thank you indeed to the officers of
the council for providing such a
detailed response to my question
for questions the one question i'd like
to come back with is
you identify within the response that
sure but sherbourne house
of no decisions been made about the
future use of that building given the
importance of the provision of housing
to people within team bridge and the
works of the council can be doing to
facilitate the delivery of homes
for the people that need them can i ask
when the
um council will be coming forward with a
detailed policy
that addresses how this council is going
to deliver all homes for
all people within team bridge
thank you thank you for that council
boulevard
would you like to respond no councillor
wrigley uh thank you chair
sorry i was waiting to be invited to
respond thank you yeah absolutely yeah
um council blu will see that the uh
housing
and homeless strategies indeed in the
answer to the question housing and
homeless strategies are being
worked on and they will come before the
council in the new year
when all counsellors will have an
opportunity to comment on them then
okay thank you for that so moving on now
to a question from cancer declarance
you've had a response count to the
clearance
would you like to ask a supplementary
uh yes please chairman if i may okay
um would i first of all like to thank
the thank you the
executive member for homes and
communities for his answer
my question to be would be to him
was not expecting uh and on the spot
answer now as it would probably be a
part two issue
with the executive member for homes and
communities be kind enough to examine
the stakeholder agreement
which outlines what would be the
financial implications should we choose
to look at withdrawing
from using the services of strata within
the next 18 months rather than letting
the current arrangements continue
and let me know his findings please of
what those financial implications would
be
thank you councillor wrigley would you
like to respond
thank you chair um we are always looking
at the arrangements with strata as we do
with all of our
such arrangements i don't think that
there is
any need to uh ask the uh
the staff to go through detailed
financial arrangements until any such
decisions might be looked at
in in detail we always have this beard
born in mind but this is really
something that goes with the
strata audit committee which is there
and the start committee
and these questions are being reviewed
at all times in those two committees
so it's an ongoing process that we look
at value for money from the strata
arrangements
i don't think there's any need right now
to look at the details of hypotheticals
thank you for that uh two questions from
councillor doors
counselor daughter first question was
regarding the tdc logo
and the leader of the council has
responded to that do you have a
supplementary for that question
uh no i'm i'm sort of reassured by the
answer on that because
uh what what i was hoping to hear is
that we
aren't uh using a lot of public funds
on on rebranding the council at a time
of a national emergency so i'm reassured
to he hear
the answer yes so there's no
supplementary there thank you
councillors in question two
um you've had a response from councillor
wrigley would you like to ask for
supplementary
yeah yes i would i mean the response was
in part
helpful uh because it pointed me at a
map though i don't believe it actually
answered my question which was
in relation to parcels of land uh that
have been purchased
uh adjacent to adopted sites on the
local plan what what the map
uh if anyone cares to click on it as
well themselves
will show is that there appears to be a
cross-head
uh parcel of land on a site called na3
which appears to be owned by tdc
uh and what i would like to be uh sort
of uh
made public and disclosed to the
residents is
what price was paid for that parcel of
land
what business case and rationale uh was
was made for the purchase of that land
uh
and a reassurance on time scales of when
that land was purchased that it was
in no way related uh or
tied to the adoption of na3 as an
allocated site
thank you councillor wrigley
i think mr chairman that's my my
question
thank you thank you chair um thank you
for your question your supplementary
question counselor doors
to help you and give detail i will reply
in writing
and publish in the members newsletter
thank you
thank you for that thank you very much
indeed so moving on now to item
seven which is the planning advisory
service findings on the review
of the planning application for length
of bridge just a little bit of
background information
here for members that are not too uh
sure about this one
on the 21st of january um uh langford
bridge farm was considered the planning
application there was considered
by the planning committee and it was
approved uh subsequent to that
on the 24th of february and notice a
motion was
it was delivered to the uh full council
um and it read to reassure elected
members and the general public we
request that the full council
back the setting up of a task and finish
group chaired by the deputy chair
of ons to investigate and clarify that
all correct
due processes were undertaken in
relation to the tabling of the
discussion of
and voting of application for langford
farm kings kurzweil
on the 21st of january members we agreed
at the time that a review would be
carried out
and no i would like to introduce
councillor briony rudkin who's actually
going to
present that review to us thank you
thank you very much chair could we go
back to the first slide please
thank you um uh thank you uh chair very
much indeed and uh i'm i'm sorry not to
be in devon uh but
in fact my home in ipswich my name is
bryony rudkin i'm the deputy leader of
ipswich foreign council
and i will introduce you to my
colleagues who are also present
at this meeting shortly if i could go to
the next slide now please
thank you so as as the chair has just
said uh in february 2020
you resolved um to reassure elected
members in the general public um by
the planning advisory service conducting
a review of the
langford bridge um application so you
can see set out there which is
the the resolution that you passed in
february
next slide please thank you as i've said
i'm briony rudkin i'm the deputy leader
of richboro council
uh and uh my colleagues on this review
were bridget downton who's the head of
business insight and corporate
communications at dorset
and richard clau crawley who is a
planning advisory service peer challenge
manager
they are both here and at the end of my
short presentation i will uh ask them
chair with your permission if they wish
to add anything to what i have said
um the process uh this was this was
we've called this a mini peer review
for those of you who who aren't aware of
the processes of
peer reviews they usually take place
over some uh
two three or even four days sometimes
and and and uh without covid obviously
they would
involve us having visited uh the
location and
an interview interviewing people in
person obviously that couldn't happen
so what we did was we conducted uh
interviews over
uh a couple of days i think it was in
total um and we did those
over um virtual platforms obviously
and obviously we reviewed a number of
the documents that were relating to the
meeting itself and we listened to the
issues of those who were concerned about
it and spoke
to a number of councillors and officers
if i could have the next slide
please the overarching messages of our
review was that the decision was made
properly
the officers report were good many of
the allegations that were made about it
were based on
misinterpretations of how planning
committees operate and the processes
were there in
however we did find that relationships
between some councillors and some
officers were challenging which meant
that uh that
in fact it there might be a perception
that uh that
things had not gone to plan and we
thought that there was a lack of
understanding of each other's
perspective
uh with regard to this relationship
breakdown
next slide please our recommendations
were that you should perhaps review the
size of your planning committee we put a
question mark there there is no
ideal size and obviously councils vary
in size
and geographic uh distribution so uh it
really would be
up to you to look at other councils and
we cannot the planning advisory service
and the local government association can
offer you help and guidance on that
we thought that likewise you should
improve your arrangements for site
visits
um site visits at the moment are
obviously difficult to conduct although
they can be conducted within social
distancing parameters
and again advice could be provided on
how you might want to do that
given your geographic um sort of uh
situation
we thought that you needed to adopt a
one-team approach and ownership to
planning committee arrangements uh we we
felt that
across different departments within the
council
that there were different people who
were responsible for different parts of
the process for example
uh how many speakers were called how
speakers were contacted and so on and
that perhaps you needed a more corporate
approach to that
and again that would also involve
counsellors in in the form of the chair
and the vice chair
um and committee members that everybody
felt that they were on the same starting
point when the when the meeting took
place
and that arrangement should be tailored
where necessary we understand that you
want to have
a fair and open price process but that
we thought that sometimes you would
disproportionate so for example the
number of speakers that you
have for an application for an extension
to a private home would be the same for
a big application and we don't think
that that's necessarily proportionate
and that you should want to hear from
more voices
in the latter case than in the former
and we thought
that overall what you really needed was
some joint officer and counsellor
training that's both of you both both
parties as it were sitting together in
the same room virtually or otherwise
covering planning and political
awareness to look to see what the art of
the possible was and that if you were
able to learn together
that that would uh that would
effectively improve um
your your the operation of your
committee
overall i believe that's my final slide
um i will now ask my colleagues if
there's anything they would like to add
and perhaps in particular
richard crawley if richard if you want
to explain what the process is for the
report
that we have the longer report thank you
the longer report uh i can now see more
of you on the screen thank you
uh richard perhaps uh chair with your
permission uh
you'd like to talk about the report
thanks brownie
uh yes just to sort of follow up so
we're here uh doing a verbal report to
you and to answer some of your questions
uh i think in about uh two weeks time
there'll be a short written report that
we can share with you
you know three or four pages long it's
not going to be war and peace
thank you richard uh bridget chair with
your permission bridget do you have
anything you wish to add
thank thank you chairman um i'm jesus
i'm having um
technical uh issues in the deepest
darkest dorset at the moment
but i can hear you but i'm it's coming
in and out and i've turned my video off
for that reason chairman so forgive me
um i haven't got anything to add but i'm
happy to um
respond to any questions if i can
provided i can hear them
thank you if bridget can't hear but she
can hear me i think she had some
difficulty hearing some of the speakers
earlier on i'm happy to repeat those
questions
chair if she needs that dude
temporarily sorry i'll mute myself
temporarily while questions are asked
because i understand about background
noise and the effect it can have
thank you for that so any members would
like to ask any questions at all
i can't see any blue hands at all ah
councillor adrian patch
thank you chair um i just note um what
one of the findings from one of the
early slides that many
of the allegations were based on
misinterpretation
um i'd just signal i hope that in the
written report
um the allegations
and the responses to them will be
detailed and unadmitted
in terms of um i'm just wondering why um
rather than saying all allegations were
based on this interpretation just many
so it seemed to leave a gap there and
i'm wondering about um
how other allegations might have been
interpreted
um the report will will give more detail
and i hope that it will satisfy um
the questions that have been asked i
think at this stage we wouldn't want to
go into specific detail about about
allegations and indeed we spoke to a
number of people
so you'll appreciate that across that
that piece we had we had lots of things
to address and we felt that this in the
headline response was the easiest way of
dealing with that
of course answer the doors
hi uh yeah thanks very much for being
here today
uh uh just a couple of questions
actually i just uh
as you know we talked at length about
this uh
about this issue um
can you confirm now that you are you've
concluded
and you are now uh delivering the report
so the investigation is concluded is
that correct
yes my colleague richard sorry i can't
see him on the screen here
richard will confirm he he's the person
who uh
presses the send button on that richard
right yes yes to confirm our
investigation is finished
so the we we had a few issues
about uh how the meeting the planning
meeting was conducted
and in terms of
presentations made within the meeting
how the meeting was shared
i'd just like to understand how you will
have come to any conclusions
on that uh on that meeting
there will be in the report uh a little
bit more about the methodology that we
use as i explained in a normal peer
review there is a long
uh fairly detailed set of key lines of
inquiry that followed as a methodology
this was this
was slightly different it was about
asking about a specific meeting
and a much smaller focus really a more
focus mini peer review it's a focus
it was a focus look at one particular
meeting and the report will
will flesh out uh the methodology that
we that we undertook
can i ask how much time you you've spent
on
this
um i couldn't answer that precisely but
it's been a great deal of time i should
imagine between the
hours that myself and my colleagues have
spent on interviews
and reading it it's been it's been quite
a quite a few i don't know if rich
richard is the one who monitors what we
all do do you have a view on that
richard
yeah i think it's been all all told
about four days
could i ask that within that four days
it might have been a good idea to watch
the planning meeting
the the the the
investigation was uh was about
uh yes i mean we didn't watch the
meeting because i don't think we had
access to the meeting richard can you
confirm what we
what we had by way of access to a
recording of that meeting it was
obviously held before um
is that a question for me because i can
answer it uh because i recorded the
meeting it was a question to my it was a
question to my colleague richard uh
crawley i'm sorry i apologize same name
sorry
uh yes i mean i think from
memory we were provided with a great
deal of material
from yourself counselor uh some of which
uh was not to go any further so i don't
really i can't remember is the honest
answer i i remember watching some of
that meeting
uh uh well i'll i'll answer very clearly
because i recall i took it upon myself
to record the planning meeting
i took it upon myself to upload the
planning meeting onto a vimeo platform
and i took it upon myself to share that
in a private manner
with you and there are analytics that
show
who has watched that meeting for how
what period of time
uh and i would say it would be
incredibly remiss
to conclude the report without having
watched
the playing meeting
we will reflect on what you've said
counselor thank you thank you
okay council have you finished now can i
move on to other councillors
yes okay councilor
hi um i haven't slept on planning for
some years but i did for several years
some time ago
um and we did have some training which
was some pretty comprehensive
um in my recollection and we had
workshops that
involved offices and it involved
counsellors and so it might be uh
prudent to repeat some of that if
that material is still available and my
main concern was
with the suggestions would be the
reduction in the size of the planning
committee because certainly in my
experience um having several members
on board at the meetings um in an area
that's quite diverse we've got coastal
towns
uh market towns we've got um out on the
malls we've got all kinds of different
areas
and having a wide representation um in
in that planning committee um for me
would be a positive thing
um so yeah that's that's my
thank you for your comments uh
councillor
uh councillor malone uh thank you chair
um yeah i'm sorry i just i can't
quite believe what i'm hearing here to
be honest
um when this was put forward
um counselor cox said it was because we
needed to lance the boil around this
decision
uh that boil uh it was formed upon
a planning meeting now for this
committee
not to have bothered watching that
planning meeting
and then come back here and make a
presentation
with a lot of i'm sorry but flannel
about the art of the possible this is
ridiculous
it is an absolute whitewash i'm sorry
but this is just not good enough
you were asked to reflect upon a
planning meeting
and you haven't watched it i'm sorry
that's just not good enough
thank you councilman malone councillor
mcgregor
uh it was just to respond to a point
that that's been raised about reducing
the size of the committee
the committee has already been reduced
to 17 members from 21
this year um and
you know i think that's probably um
reflect the
the general concern for the size of the
committee but also not reducing it too
much to maintain the size and maintain
the representation across the district
so i think
we have already taken action there thank
you thank you thank you
very much i might comment i do
appreciate that
obviously i i'm sitting here in a in a
town that's much the size of
exeter which is probably the nearest
comparison to you and i appreciate that
you know understanding
we are one place and i do appreciate the
uh coastal
and uh sort of rural and urban diversity
of team bridge and so
that is something for you to reflect on
and perhaps actually having already
changed the size
that's something you could reflect on
the effect of that change already
uh we we we put a question mark there
because it is something for you to
reflect on and perhaps perhaps
talk to others and ask them what their
experiences without us being
prescriptive about that thank you okay
thank you very much indeed now i can't
see any any more blue hands so
i would like to thank uh councillor
rudkin
uh bridgette downton
[Music]
chairman i did just put my hand up sorry
if i'm sorry it's not appearing on the
screen
sorry go ahead please i do apologize
uh thank you chairman um
i i understand what colleagues say and
it's worth revisiting
um what we actually asked the planning
advisory service to do
which was to reassure elected members
and the general public
the independent planning advisory
service is invited by team rich council
to review all relevant
matters and processes relating to the
granting the application at langford
bridge
and to report his conclusions to the
council
so hopefully the uh the work that our
colleagues from
the planning advisory service have done
um
was uh widespread and looked at that now
many of us uh probably felt that
planning
had come to a conclusion and obviously
at the time
back in february some members felt that
there were things that deserved a review
and council
uh commissioned this independent report
from the planning advisory service so
i hear what some colleagues say about
well did you look at the the planning
meeting and i heard
uh councillor rudkin say uh that they
would
reflect on uh that request from
councillor dawes
but i don't think that detracts from the
headline comments that
the planning advisory service which is
independent of the council in which
council was content to report
and ask them to do this work to look at
the
the application and all the relevant
processes
so it strikes me that it's quite right
that council
has the presentation we've had today
first
and then the report follows and
i think there's much in there that we
can draw from
both in terms of how we can improve our
own planning services
and the relationships that have been
identified
and it would be helpful to hear from our
colleagues from the planning advisory
service
how we might go about that or whether
that's going to be in the report
specifically uh and if there's anything
else that we should be doing because we
all want planning
to work well but that's different of
necessity isn't it to the fact that
um at any planning meeting there are
going to be some people who don't like
the decision of the committee because
they're either won or lost and there'll
be some people who do like it because
they've won or lost
but it is important to get the process
right
and that's what i thought council was
striving for back in
in january february when we agreed to do
this work so
i would like to thank councillor rudkin
and colleagues from the planning
advisory service
for their presentation just today for
the work they've done
so far and i look forward to receiving
the report and most importantly drawing
from that
lessons that we can all take in terms of
looking at what we can do to enhance
our planning service here in team bridge
and thank you very much chair
thank you um i've just noticed that
councillor dawes has put his hand up
again
yeah yes i have yeah i mean uh sort of
just in answer to the leader of the
council there because he did back the
motion
uh to bring forward the investigation
and we did
enter into it in good faith uh and when
we had
the zoom meeting uh with with the uh
planning advisory service and and the
counsellor
uh we were reassured that there would be
due process
undertaken and uh for us to uh
have faith in that which we did and it's
nearly a year
on since the since the planning meeting
uh
and i i i'm just flabbergasted that
we were talking about a planning meeting
and
how a decision uh and recommendations
could be made
without even looking at the planning
meeting i would be
embarrassed myself if i were
proposing these findings i'm really
really sorry we did show good faith
uh i'm afraid it was misplaced thank you
councillor dawes
so once again i would like to to thank
councillor rudkin
bridget downton richard crawley and paul
clark for delivering this presentation
today
and we look forward to receiving your
report in a couple of weeks thank you
very much indeed
item eight on the agenda which is the
statement of accounts
including the annual governance
statement which i believe is initially
going to be presented by councillor
keeling
thank you mr chairman um i'd just like
to say thank you to julie massey
andrew davis from grant thornton's um
this was not an easy task uh for grant
thornton
as they um would normally have taken
this task
um at team bridge itself um
and um because of the situation we're in
they had to do it remotely
mainly remotely and but i'd just like to
thank them for their hard work on this
and pass over to the chairman of the
audit scrutiny
council morgan thank uh you
you um i'd like to reiterate that um
as usual grant thornton always make a a
good effort for us and they're extremely
professional
i'd also like to thank our own staff
who've continued to work through
these issues that we have to do every
year anyway and they've done it despite
very difficult circumstances so thank
you very much to our own staff
i'll read the recommendation which i
will move is that the council resolves
to approve
the 2019-2020 statement of accounts
including the annual government
statement
and letter of representation as
recommended by the audit scrutiny
committee subject to any final
adjustments agreed with the external
auditors
to be reported to council and note the
audit findings report from grant
thornton and approve the actions arising
from the action plan
so i've moved that this has already been
approved unanimously by the audit
scrutiny committee
um so i just need a second to please i'd
like to second that mr chairman
thank you very much indeed so we have a
poser and a second
would anybody like to comment on that at
all
i can't see any blue hand so can we go
to the vote please
this is agenda item eight
shall i would you like me to read the
recommendation again yes please
yeah please okay the recommendation that
the council
resolve to approve the 19 the 2019-2020
statement of accounts
including the annual governance
statement and letter of representation
as
recommended by the audit scrutiny
committee subject to any final
adjustments agreed with the external
auditors
to be reported to council and note the
audit findings report from grant
thornton and approve the actions arising
from the actual plan
all these reports are in your reports
pack and they've already been
approved unanimously by the audit
scrutiny committee thank you for that
answer the fix you've put your hand up
is that inadvertent or
cancer effects you need to unmute
yourself
there you go sorry mr chairman thank you
i was at the roll call but i was
wasn't heard and i've missed out on all
the voting so far i've been
in through all the meetings so could
somebody please put me
on the voting list please fix my names
okay thank you most certainly thank you
so can we go back to the
roll call please now oh councillor hook
gordon hook
councillor hook
can you hear me now yes right thank you
sorry
um i i'm very pleased to see the report
read the report complement those
responsible and clearly a lot of good
work
in very difficult circumstances has been
progressing
um and i think that we you know we
should record again our thanks to the
uh staff and members concerned because
it's been
a trying time on the finance front if i
could just raise one or two points about
the the content of the audit report
however
um probably for my own education as much
as anything
i think it's page 13 it says we have
concluded
that uh the management process is
adequate
can i ask if there are variations on
that is it
inadequate or is there brilliant
outstanding fantastic
rubbish dreadful appalling is there a
degree of
uh competence or whatever and and we get
an adequate as opposed to
inadequate which is good that's that's
one one point um
i think also it's an opportunity perhaps
first um
to look at the the um the impact of the
new homes bonus and the business rates
is there an update on any of that
because the future appeared to be
uncertain
and i just wondered whether there's any
more recent
information um and would it be
appropriate at some stage not
necessarily now but at some stage
to look at the reserves and um
the use of them and whether we have any
further scope there or
when when we might tighten the belt
again or
there's a lot of questions about the
reserves and i just think that that
might be an issue for
an ons debate if if not now
two or three questions there i don't
know if anybody can cast any light on
any of them thank you
morgan or cancer i don't have that
information but perhaps the chief
financial officer does
surely thank you could i could i come in
on point
point one it's andrew davis from grant
thornton please do
yeah um i'll let sort of martin respond
on
on the new homes bonus side of things
but just in terms of
the the value for money uh
the side of things um
adequate is is as good as it gets um
the arrangements in place are either
they're either adequate or then or
they're not
um the sort of there are levels
there are levels below adequate which is
where we would we can
issue a qualified value from a
conclusion where we're saying that the
arrangements are not adequate and
that in itself has got two subsets one
where we're saying it's
they're not adequate for one particular
reason
or not they're not adequate full stop
and then
so there's different levels so the worst
one is kind of where we're saying it's
adverse
so except for is sort of a so we got
adequate
except for and um
basically not not adequate so that would
be
the sort of the worst case scenario so
where the council is at the moment
we've raised a recommendation um
around the need to take action because
there's a lot of certainty out there
with covert
um and and more so than there was in the
past
the council already had a a sort of a
budget gap so what we've recommended
that is
uh which again is is isn't isn't rocket
science you know the council knows that
it needs an intervention
um it's just reiterating the importance
of that given that
given the context of coving and
everything else that's going on
thank you for that i'm glad that
adequate is as good as it gets
so counselor are you content with the
answers you receive now
yeah but that was fine yeah i just um
thought it was worth raising and and
you know if that adequate is as good as
it gets as i say that's that's
really encouraging and chairman if i can
add on the issue of reserves uh as i
hope all councils will know
we're in the process of preparing the
budget for next year looking at
all matters so the issue of reserves is
very much
uh on the council's agenda thank you
chairman thank you
okay oh councillor adrian patch you have
a question
thank you chair um yes having looked at
the papers
um for this item um i couldn't actually
see any detail on the annual government
statement i just wondered if anybody um
would be able to give us
maybe someone from the audit scrutiny
committee or an officer would be able to
give us um just a very brief overview
of what's covered by the annual
government governance statement
we've got actually financial officer
here who's
raised his hand a couple of times okay
yeah if i if i can just go back to
councillor hook's question first
around the new homes bonus um
so we have no assurance from government
yet as to whether we will get any
funding
from uh from government on new homes
bonus going forward
um in last year's um proposals they said
that they were going to
stop new homes bonus going forward um
and they would look at an alternative
form of housing
funding um that still hasn't transpired
as
an option um so at the moment we're
still unclear whether there will be
an opportunity for new homeless bonus to
continue
we've made representations to government
to
clarify whether that will continue we
have done a return which
covers our council tax dwelling numbers
and in the guidance notes there it
talked about filling out certain
elements of that return
um should new homes bonus continue
so there's a a bit of hope that
somewhere
along the line they're still thinking
about it but we won't know until
um we get um the
detailed information in our provisional
settlement from funding from government
in december
so i hope that sort of covers off where
we are with that
um the annual governance statement
itself um
is is part of the um a statement of
accounts
so you can have a look in there um um it
comes
on page 119 onwards um so it's been
included in the um budget papers for
both the drafts of accounts and the
final set of accounts
um and basically it covers
it's it's a review of how we're
using our public money and making sure
that we're
using it efficiently effectively and
economically
um and it looks all the goodness ranges
we've got in place to ensure
uh our internal controls are correct and
and we are
it's a it's a check if you like to make
sure that we're doing things in the
right
way so there's a lot of stuff covered in
there and i wouldn't propose to go
through it
line by line but there's quite a bit of
detail in there around our our
governance framework
stakeholder engagement all that type of
thing and also we updated this
this year's one to cover the impacts of
kobit 19
and what we were doing in relation to
that thank you
thank you for that martin if there
aren't any more questions perhaps we can
go to the vote now please
councillor austin
four chancellor bradford
abstain councillor bullevant
paul councillor clarence
cancer colclough cancer connect
councillor david cox paul councillor
hugh cox
councillor doors i'm staying
cancer dewhurst or
councillor eden council edens had to
step out of the meeting
okay councillor goodman bradbury
or cancer gribble
or councillor haines
raw cancer hocking
or councillor gordon hook
councillor jackie hook paul
councillor jeffrey
councillor keeling four
council care as well
councillor mcgregor four
councillor morgan councillor malone
um yeah four councillor nutley
councillor nuttall
councillor head it difficulties chairman
sorry
councillor four
cancer fips four
cancer persa four
councillor rolison or
councillor russell
council swain four councillor taylor
councillor thorne or councillor wrigley
or councillor parker four
councillor john pederek
that's that's carrie chair thank you
very much indeed for that
item nine recommendation from the
standards committee
i'm going to ask committee chair
councillor linda pedrick
to introduce it thank you chair
full council requested at its meeting
early september
that the committee reconsider its
membership as it has not been reviewed
other than within the context
of independent members for some years
having considered such the committee
unanimously recommends that the
membership be six elected district
council
council members i would like to propose
this recommendation
is there a seconder for that please
chairman yes i'll um
second if i may chairman uh just say a
few words chad please do yes
um i entirely support the recommendation
from councillor pedro
colleagues and chairman i'd anticipated
that councillor dawes was going to ask
me a supplementary question
to the when we did the council's
questions i have prepared the
supplementary the chairman if you learn
only a moment i want to apologize to
councillor dawes and to the council at
our last meeting chairman in replying to
the council of dawn's question
i used a phrase which upset councillor
doors i did not intend to do that and
apologize to him in council
and thank you very much shalom you're
the opportunity i wanted to say that now
i'd anticipated being able to do that
earlier i second cancer pedric's
uh proposal with regard to standards
thank you chairman
anybody else wish to comment on the
proposal
counselors are you wishing to comment on
this proposal or respond to going to the
connect
well i think it'd be appropriate to do
both actually uh
but i i i acknowledged that uh point
from the leader of the council and it's
uh
clearly appreciated um
in terms of the proposal um
the issue that uh i would have having
been through the standards procedure
would
be a root and branch
review that needs to be done and i would
also reflect on my
pro supplementary question that wasn't
answered
which is an observation from a
neighbouring council
uh about the uh propriety the
the uh the probity the the the the level
of standards
uh dealt out by our
standards committee so i would actually
suggest that it needs reviewing in a
root and branch manner
thank you for that council of doors any
other councillors like to comment at all
in that case can we go to the vote
please
councillor austin for council bradford
against council bullamant billament
councillor clarence or cancer colclough
oh councillor connect paul
councillor david cox i'm for it i do
take
a council doors point and i think
outside of this we do need to have a
review of the whole system
councilor hugh cox four
cancer doors against
cancer dewhurst
council goodman bradbury or
cancer gribble
councillor haines
war cancer hocking
or cancer gordon hook
with reservations for jackie hook
counselor jeffrey councillor keeling
or cancer care as well
paul councillor mcgregor abstain
councillor morgan
cancer malone jones
councillor netley four
four councillor linda pedreck
councillor phipps boar
council four councillor rolison
or councillor russell
councillor swain four
councillor taylor
councillor thorne four councillor
wrigley
paul council parker or
councillor john pedreck
chair that's carrie chair oh sorry
sorry chair um i i i've been told that
you couldn't hear
my my vote because i had my my
microphone up i
i did vote for thank you thank you
chair that's carrie chair thank you very
much indeed thank you
item 10 recommendation from licensing
and regulatory committees
review of statement of licensing policy
council david cox
thank you very much indeed can i thank
and praise the officers for their
diligence and work in doing this it was
accepted unanimously by the committee
and i hope full council will will back
us on doing that
so um it's merely updating as we're
required to by legislation
our licensing policy there are some
changes but not
major changes uh i think it's good good
piece of work done by our officers there
and i have no no qualms in moving that
we adopted
seconded and that's been seconded by
councilman gregory councillor mcgregor
oh councilman gregory okay thank you for
that
anybody wishing to comment at all
in that case can we go to the vote
please
counselor austin
councillor bradford four
council bullivant four
councillor clarence or councillor
colclough
counselor connect four
councillor david cox paul councillor
hugh cox
cancer doors
for councillor hawking
or cancer gordon hook
paul councillor jackie hook
or cancer jeffrey
cancer keeling or
cancer care as well oh council mcgregor
or councillor morgan
cancer malone
cancer nutslay i did put my blue hand up
in actual fact to second this but i also
wanted to thank the officers especially
andrew furness
and marie downing for the actual work
they did on this
um but obviously my hand wasn't noticed
thank you but four
apologies councillor
four cancer parker khan four
cancer patch four cancer pit
four council linda pedreck
four
russell councillor swain
four councillor taylor
councillor thorne or
councillor wrigley or councillor parker
or councillor john pederick four
chair through you i'd just like to check
uh councillor austin
and councillor colclough um
council austin what was your vote please
i couldn't uh can't come for austin
you're on mute
i voted for four okay and councillor
cole clough
i couldn't hear
chair the votes carried okay thank you
very much indeed for that
thank you item 11
on the agenda is a notice of motion
which is going to be presented by
councillor swain
now initially when the agenda was
published
uh it advised that that it would be
heard by this
by the council and if we wanted to
debate it
then then two-thirds of the council
would have to be in favor of the debate
um otherwise it would be referred to the
relevant committee
and the relevant committee is the
executive but i understand no that this
is going to be referred
to the executive committee anyway uh
councillor swain would you like to
elaborate on that please
um thank you yes i'm happy for it to be
referred to the executive
and i will simply introduce it now if
that's acceptable chair
please do thank you um four years ago
the people of the united states elected
donald trump as their president
the majority had actually voted for
hillary clinton but they used first past
the post and a block voting in their
electoral college system
this can result in a win for one
candidate when the majority
prefer the other in their more recent
elections there were five u.s cities
where a proposal for ranked choice
voting was included in the ballot paper
all five of those proposals were
successful
this week on the 18th of november uh the
welsh parliament
voted to pass the local government and
elections wales bill
this gives councils in wales the power
to change from first pastor post to
proportional representation
using single transferable vote it also
means that wales now joins scotland in
allowing voters aged 16 and 17.
these young adults can leave home they
can start a family they can get married
they can work pay taxes and can join the
armed forces
all at the age of 16 but under the
current rules with elections every four
years
they could be almost 22 before they have
any say in the running of the country
in my ward of ken valley and the last
administration there were two
conservative councillors with less than
half to vote
and no representative for the other half
when i stood for election i promised to
fight that injustice
and now including myself all three
councillors for ken valley are liberal
democrats
with less than half to vote i'm still
fighting this injustice because this is
not about advantages or disadvantages
for our parties
it's about making democracy better at
representing the views and needs of all
in our communities
it's time we fix this and i hope members
of the council and the executive
will support this motion towards doing
that thank you chair i'll move to motion
as set out uh thank you very much indeed
councillor swain
um now i understand that this will go to
the executive for consideration
so therefore there's no need for us to
discuss it or comment on it at all no
so thank you very much indeed for that
the next item on the agenda is a part
two item
but i see we're fast approaching half
11.
so again i suggest that we take a 10
minute comfort break
and return at 11 30 but before you go
please
um i need to advise the members of
public that are streaming
watching this on on facebook and and
youtube
that when when we return we will go into
a part two
which is an item that is it is not in
the public interest
sorry it is in the public interest due
to financial sensitivity issues
concerning the council and third party
stakeholders
so therefore we will exclude the press
and the general public so
at this time no shortly after we go into
our comfort break
then we will start live streaming and
when we return after our comfort break
then we will go into part two
mr chairman democratic services first
please sarah
chair you need a proposal and a second
please to uh go into part two and we'll
have to do roll call vote
i propose it so sorry we can do that
before we go into our comfort break then
yes
yes i'll do that before we go into our
company so i can stop like yeah
so so so i need in that case i need to
read at the recommendation so
recommended that under section 100a of
bleep 4
of the local government act the press
and public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in the relevant paragraphs
of part three of schedule 12a of the act
so can we please cover the vote on that
it's been proposed
seconded
council austin
councillor austin
or councillor bradford
councillor bradford she's left the
meeting
thank you councillor bill event four
councillor clarence or cancer colclough
paul councillor connect four
councillor david cox or councillor hugh
cox
councillor doors
cancel the doors
council goodman bradbury or
councillor gribble four
councillor haines or
councillor hawking or
cancer gordon hook councillor jackie
hook
cancer jeffrey cancer healing
or cancer kurzweil
cancer mcgregor or cancer morgan
or cancer malone again
cancer nutley four
councillor four cancer parker khan
councillor patch what
council pete councillor linda pedreck
four councillor phipps
four council persa four
please i have to go and have my car mot
so i'm going to have to leave the
meeting for this
item thank you council swain
for cancer taylor
cancer thorne or councillor wrigley
or councillor parker or
councillor john pederick
so apologies for the confusion there
members so we'll take a
a ten minute comfort break and return at
11 35.
thank you very much that was carrie
chair
thank you i'll
stop the live streaming